yes excuse me  i noticed that you were doing 81 on the  65.  do you like to explain yourself  um  good morning officer i um it's it's it's  one o'clock good afternoon  sir are you is something wrong are you  on a substance of some sort or some sort  no no i i'm just a little nervous  because i don't know why i've been  pulled over you don't know why you've  been pulled though do you want to take a  guess i mean i think maybe i was going a  little bit faster a little bit faster  than the speed limit you were going 16  miles an hour faster  in relation to 65 miles an hour as the  speed limit you were going about 25  percent too fast  i totally understand i majored in math  is it an emergency  i do have to get back home to staten  island um i haven't been with my uh kids  uh for a few days and um i do i just  would like to say no more  get out of here  what's this on your front seat  that's um  smells like [ __ ]